hey everyone welcome back to part three
of the autumn marathon tournament this
is a finale five hours of cool exciting
maybe slightly dubious games a lot of
fun and interesting gambits uh i checked
off a lot of items on my chest bucket
list in this one and as usual every game
is time stamped in the video description
so feel free to hop around
and browse all the cool openings i
played throughout now before we get into
the chess i do have a brand new and
delicious sponsor to thank for this
video i want to give a huge thank you to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video if
you haven't heard of them hellofresh is
a meal delivery service they send you
fresh pre-portioned ingredients straight
to your doorstep and you can count on
them to make home cooking easy fun and
affordable for those of you that want a
low stress home cooking experience
holofresh is the way to go they have a
vast number of menu items to suit
vegetarian calorie smart and
family-friendly preferences and it's
just a great time saver as well and it
just makes for a much smoother
experience without the hassle of grocery
shopping now very recently i had the
pleasure of cooking a hello fresh meal
alongside my friend and elite
grandmaster ilya nizhnik we cooked some
poison sweet potato mushroom bowls and
they were absolutely delicious the
recipe was super easy to follow and the
final product not only looked amazing
but it was super super tasty so i do
have a special offer for my viewers if
you go to hellofresh.com
and use code chess14
you can get up to 14 free meals and
three free gifts
and i really hope you enjoy hellofresh
as much as i did
now let's get back to the chess
anyway i'm still top hundred i'm 99th
place let's go quick and quiet trying to
pass me
so there's five hours and two minutes
left i got some tea got some energy bar
this is a very small piece of my energy
bar
okay
let's jump in
sound
why is there no sound
ah
there is sound
hello from sweden hello
thank you the beast
there's a possibility i'll be going to
sweden at the end of the year
there's a tournament i might be playing
in
um
i'll keep people posted
anyway we have a reverse dutch
uh this move might be coming
yeah white wants to attack me
i think i just have to hold my ground
let me go for hello from the uk smiley
face
oh let's get some smiley faces in the
chat
welcome welcome pimpa
um
trying to remember how the pieces move
i'll play c4 some idea of this
white's attack could be a little bit
unsettling but
i'm trying to gain space
on the queen side
yeah hello to more people welcome to all
the fight the first time chatters
good to see you guys
okay this square is a really nice
orifice in white's territory
might be going for the triple up
also apologies i will be eating for
a little bit of the first portion of the
stream
this is my breakfast
shout out to you can
tasty bar
um
i kind of like this move unleashes a
bishop
prepares knight b3
prevents knight c5
considering taking and playing bishop c5
maybe i can start with uh this move
trying to induce this
and then queen b8
another idea is to take knight c5 and
then try and get the knight to d3
another idea
make a gun
i like another idea is to make a gun
oh it's true
i'm also thinking takes in this hi there
i think i'll do that i'll make a fork
and then maybe a gun
now i am entering
uh
i'll start with this and then i'll take
the rook
i was gonna say we'd be entering like
optical bishops situation
if
white were to take
now life is good
white's in trouble
okay the gun is being formed
alekhine's gun
thank you everyone for subbing
um oh i have to be careful here
these queries are tender but i have a
darker bishop
i'm stuck working on a paper and wish i
had time to play today here's 50 hoping
you get your top whoa
good luck and have fun thanks for the
content smile that's so kind smile back
good luck with your paper
i hope i can provide some
some entertainment on your breaks
okay i just want to win quickly here
also this is a massive fork which i have
to still be aware of
i think after h5 queen each bishop b7
uh baby baby oh baby baby
akko are becoming a baby
and this queen is about to be okay that
was nice
99
okay staying within the top hundred
thanks for the brilliant caro can video
oh thank you i'll try and play some more
uh
crushing the caro khan
oh i lost to this person twice yesterday
nobody's working let's try and uh
build a streak
before i start because working
thank you torco3
torque 203
um this is
interesting so i'm accepting the gambit
right here i have this 95.
eric
thank you banana peel pancake
hmm
i have no idea this is theory
looks like some sort of theory
it's a little bit unpleasant
or very unpleasant
i'll play b4
expecting knight e4
thanks for the
donation
my name
oh
appreciate the the generosity so far
this pawn's a little bit tender
oh but there's a funny line
i'll play this if knight takes i might
have knight c3
the castling is logical
and then
i think i just play this
i'll lose a c pawn i'll complete
development
and life will go on
make you nerd of many things
yeah the top 100 bits
trying to get to top 50.
it should be doable but it's going to
take focus and persistence and
composure patience
uh let's not blunder a bishop
okay maybe go for c5
c5 is very typical in these for the
catalan type positions
if you can play it and it doesn't lose
anything it's usually a decent move
okay we both have the bishop hair
i defend the bishop getting ready for
the rooks to come in
this work is a little bit tied down
although
let's start with this
f2 is a bit tender
maybe this move
just making small improvements
making luft preventing possibilities of
like h4 bishop g5
okay so oh no my pawn
knight a5 i have bishop f2
wow
[Music]
that's such a bold move
i want to punish this move like play
this
but that doesn't work i have f5 maybe
there's bishop a8 maybe bishop eight
idea to now defend the bishop with a
rook
threatening some cool thing
i don't even know if this is a threat
because takes and takes and queen moves
the other idea is to play queen a7
so defending the pawn creating the
battery
enabling bishop e7
trying to be multi-purpose
there's this kind of this pin
i have knight not f64 bishop e7
i think knight f6
pressure against the pawn i mean e5 may
be possible
oh no
i blundered
i kind of blundered
or did i blunder
g2
how do i resolve this
i've rooked e4 there we go okay
i think i'm alive
yeah there's this pin
why does maybe considering taking
[Music]
rook t4 saves me
and now the queen is a bit stuck
i went from thinking i was maybe losing
to now thinking i'm maybe winning
when does the queen move h3 right here
throw in the check
what
opponent may be throwing in the towel
[Music]
was unexpected
i'll take with pawn
i like the bishop here
mcqueen a8
f3
d5
rook team one coming
still takes a lot of work to win this
maybe f5 here
generally if i have a single minor piece
like a bishop i want the pawns now on
different color than the bishop
just to maximize square control
um
[Music]
i'm thinking about
the plan of e5 e4
there's knight g6
i gotta move quicker too
i'll play this first here then here
i also have a pawn so pawn for queen and
knight or
queen and pawn and rook and knight
okay i want to play this and this
bishops move like this
mini l
okay
yeah this is going to be difficult to
win
it's very solid
i gotta play a bunch of quick moves too
losing the pawn i guess i am
this pawn's a bit tender
okay so i'm trying to put white and zuma
now rooks tie down knights tie down here
i win the rook
if takes i can lock up the king
if king h3 i have queen f3 which is
really nice
and now i'm liking this move
white is really close to being zugged
[Music]
yeah i think i just uh i'll optimize the
king verse
and then push the pawn
is realizing the danger
i mean nothing else can really move for
like
e4 and queen f3 come in
and then if i can win this pawn it's
over
there we go
do i be fancy take the rook
why not
okay that was a nice little grind
i felt good about that one
almost a small hiccup in the middle game
okay let's go
two out of two of the stream
94th place
trying to build a streak
okay i'll be here
opponent berserk's i berserk
i was hoping for e6 pre-move
i'm playing the nasal wasp gambit
100 finish coming
hey
you smell hopefully correctly
okay we're about to enter a funny line i
think this
i was expecting bishop d4
wow okay this is still kind of funny
hitting c7 now
check
i guess knight e7 is coming
weird position
not feeling great about this actually
i want to play this move
i mean slide down to the knight
okay now i'm feeling better a little bit
it's still really weird i'm down three
pawns but i'm doing things with my
things
yeah now i can
take and take
oh it's still not clear
okay now it's looking pretty clear
i think i don't know
[Music]
check and meat
it's a fork mate
it was fate
okay if here it would be a nice little
fork mate
let's go
three other three
i did finish yesterday's turn or
yesterday's stream
with the five move win of the england
gambit trap
so i guess i'm four in a row
okay
at my energy bar to keep me going
80 first
a lot of people have been falling into
this trap rook c8
and then the rook gets trapped
and so many decently strong players just
walk into this including gm's
people aren't used to running into
bishop e5 in the london
um
i kind of want to play this move
just for the giggles
uh
let's do it
there's the prospect of preventing block
from castling
here here here and then here
or here
thank you tmt ny
new time prime sub
ooh opponents giving me a taste of my
own medicine
lights ready to come in though
so both of our kings are stuck in the
center
which king will be more stuck
only time will tell
okay my queen feels like an oyster now
preventing bishop z7 which is kind of
important
i play this move
it feels really close to winning
let's do it
f6 i take and then king f8 i move the
bishop back
oh but there's king d8
there's also that move
oh this position is a little bit more
confusing than anticipated
i just reached top twenty thousand
boss
i think there's just a little bit over
twenty thousand players playing
i'm so proud of you
i'm just calculating here trying to
figure out
intricacies of this position
i think i should move back
not what i want to do but
kind of what i have to do
in 94. f4 it's
feels a bit passive
also feels like maybe i could have
gotten more
at least there's tension if c4 i can
happily castle
otherwise
my plan
probably knight d4 coming
67 was unexpected
i still want to play knight d4
chase away this bishop maybe b4
also maybe 94 f3 king f2 is one way to
untangle
i think you ship hippo
four months
hey it's pam welcome back
it's hard to look at chat so closely
oh i will be playing in the squid chest
tomorrow it's a squid chess games
hosted by anna kremling should be pretty
fun
i have no idea like what the games are
which i think is kind of the point
should make things interesting
okay so i'll play f3
wow bishop d8
uh
i mean there's queen h3 get after this
move
let's move
i'm trying i'm trying i want to play
queen d6 soon
oh i didn't see that
okay well now i'm just in trouble
ah
how about this this is kind of bad ah oh
it's such a good opening too
okay i might as well
take
be sad
um
have this move
well this position is crumbling that's
so sad
got the opening trap
knight c6
it takes takes takes
should be three
still trying to fight
[Music]
oh it's hari krishnan gifting 50. thanks
so much
that's so kind
welcome back
we're just in time for my pain
no
yeah
i miss queen c1 actually
three pawn
pawn
i should probably resign
but i'm playing on because i have pawns
i kind of have a fortress too
the fortress is about to crack
let's take
i'm not so optimistic here
okay i mean it all comes down to these
things
the last survivors
hoping for this
this this
well played
you never know though you never know
until you do know
okay i resigned
no traps in this position no still made
traps
oh that was rough
i should at least learn from my mistakes
i mean i really like the position here
when c5 happened
gg596
so i have options
but it's not completely winning for
white
took some effort to resolve
uh okay next time i would just take
castle not even allow bishop d3 i think
the simplest
okay
lesson learned
i still have my bucket list from
yesterday
i haven't yet played a potato opening or
a medusa gambit
uh maybe i'll go for medusa
i can't
oh or a cottage gambit
i haven't played the goddess yet
i would need white to play d4
okay you can't play the goddess against
knight c3
hey it's gary gary wakes up to me nice
uh let's take and maybe queen d5
interesting
how to do this
knight c6
d4 is coming play this move
and tickle the pawn
trying to induce d3
i'm realizing this is already
uncomfortable
oh maybe i can get a castle fork
castle fork is on my list
but how to do it
i need to play this
b6 b6 seems overly weakening
i have this move
where this move
bishop g2 still coming
i could just play b6 now
looks solid
or maybe this move
this move looks even more solid rook b
sub rook b7 i take
but bishop g2 takes takes
there's eventual rook b7
there's a really funny line
ah it doesn't work though
i want it to work
i want to take here
i'm taking my time because there's
something that
that's really beautiful that could
potentially happen
i think i just take
maybe
i'm here play this
not the best move but
oh there's a really funny line too it's
not gonna happen though
look at this
well now i try don't drop the thing
play this so if takes i take here
i threaten the double fork
all right threaten um double threat of
this and this
me dot twitch.tv user notice hashtag m
rosen
wait what who said that
someone said that
i can castle here too i
oh there's so many funny looking lines
i want to play this actually
c4 uh let's just take
oh the funny line this move and then oh
it doesn't really work
i might still do it though
how to do this
i trapped the rook
i gotta move too
i'm taking too long
[Music]
maybe this first
giving up on queensland counseling
we're going for 81. eric kim rose and
pog
hey
okay now i'm threatening to take and
meeting ideas
oh no
the great and powerful rosen
i feel less great and less powerful here
though
because
maybe i'm still alive it's just
terrifying
these lines are really scary
grab this move
i think i have this move
it seems like there should be a tactic
for white but i don't think there is
because i control eight
it takes takes
i have nine seconds left
now here
and then i'll just make a loof
everything is fine
okay upper rook now
yeah this is completely winning
i want to get the other rook in
um
here's my mating ideas
oh my pawns attacked
this first and then maybe this
it would have been really bad to hang g7
there
i think i want to play uh h5 and then
try and
create some bishop f1 mating ideas
also the rook's hanging so now i have a
double threat of bishop f1 and taking
the rook
okay
let's go
let's go
thanks everyone for being here i'm
singer welcome back
oh saying the green powerful rosen
okay i feel somewhat great and powerful
what's
berserk hopefully i'm not becoming
overconfident
uh yeah this is a fun line takes knight
b4 hi eric can you add bishop scam bit
on your list too the line goes e4 e5 f4
x4 and bishop c4 jim rosen angry goose
em rosen angry goose em rose and angry
goosim rose and steak sticks and stick
okay
the bishop's gambit has been added
if i end up gamuting a bishop i might
also include that
as a way of accomplishing the item
also this is already really pleasant for
black
there's a square
bishop f1 is playable
i think now it's just a happy french
i gotta move quicker though
um
yeah white was just going for trades
it's still
preferable for bach
just kind of keep the pace
maybe some g5 move
at some point
consider taking the knight
but this looks more fun
with the bishop on c4
the queen in
okay so hitting the knight knights
pinned
uh calculate knight c3 knight g4 h3
f5 ideas
i'll start with this provoke h3
poking and trotting
i can go for h5h4
and it's basically full domination
all areas of the board
and yeah i didn't want to allow knight
b6
i do lose a pawn but
i don't really care about the queen side
anymore or do i
an annoying move
i have to take
i'm going all in
we're all out
play f3
really
h1
i do this
[Music]
running rook g3
you gotta keep the pace
this is coming
always on croissant
okay g2
windy to queen h6 can you say the london
system is the greatest opening of all
time with a genuine accent
a genuine like a london not right now i
gotta focus
thankfully i saw an h7 coming from a
distance
now it looks to be force meat
it broke here the last tricky move
oh that's also kind of tricky
ah
all over
i didn't see the mates
that's so sad
i mean
it's a draw so i didn't get flagged was
there
made
mates
six after queen f1
oh queen f1 knight d4 that's kind of
hard to see
we go away and then come back
ah what to do
okay back to tournament
back to
okay so i got some points here
i got one point for that
okay
playing
well it's not berserk but let's play
aggressively
um bishop c4
some kind of weird ponziani
type thing
i want to play d4
yeah unfortunately i can't really do a
british accent if i could i would
probably do it all the time
but it's just something i'm kind of
physically incapable of
okay i'm just playing based on intuition
this looks pleasant
i mean there's a pin but i have a lot of
things supporting e5
wouldn't mind if the d-file opens or the
e-file opens
not quite winning though
uh maybe this move or maybe this move
the bishop six a bishop six i take yeah
i think
i think this is called for
so here we just trade and i'll be up
upon
not the most exciting
climax to the attack but
sometimes that's how attacks go you you
be aggressive and then you
get away with a small amount of material
and then you have to grind the end game
you wrote dorado
no genuine accent like you sincerely
mean it
oh i thought you just meant a british
accent
oh
you just want me to talk genuinely
i do that all the time
i think
what did you want me to say
can you say oh okay
a london system is the greatest opening
of all time
i hope that's
satisfactory
although the staffer gambit is a close
competitor of london
also did i even i didn't even play the
london this game
maybe i'll play the london next white
game i get
goomba
first time prime sub
thank you so much oh you're welcome
thank you ro dorado for all the bits and
kindness
uh i don't even know to do
let's play this move
i feel like this knight could be better
somehow like this this
wow
very fancy
rook d3
over d391 wow
by playing at four
we trade
it's a really annoying move i guess king
f3
calculating this and then this and then
this and then this
then this and then
walks back to d2
i might be going in a little bit too
deep i mean knight b4 is kind of scary
but it's an end game king power
oh gauri has a funny joke
what do you call a factory that makes
okay products
a satisfactory
and if the products are not okay
then it's unsatisfactory
any reason to play knight f3 second
oh d493 and then c4 uh usually to avoid
gambits
like budapest or
the alvin counter gambit
there's probably other nuances too
you get some different version of
queen's game accepted
black has to commit to a second move so
always like going to london depending
what black plays
i was thinking f4 here
although it kind of leaves a bishop a
bit weak
but maybe it's okay
here i have this and then king goes back
to f3
i'm trying to push for a win
oh we're still in emo only
yeah emo only will be turned off after
this game
or during this
game once in a while email only mode is
nice
let the mods in vips converse
is a board slightly out of frame my bad
uh i probably like played with it
when i was sleep deprived earlier
i had this move
you don't really see the point of this
okay feeling good about this now
uh oh there's a funny mate okay so f5
takes and then knight f4 threatening the
rook but also threatening maiden one
hey it's a fork mate
it was fate
that was a nice finish
let's go upon play the crucial role
knights were happy
okay
going for top 80.
thank you r3 it
stopping at tier 1 for six months in
advance
really appreciate that
okay
oh i forgot to play a london the best
opening ever
i'll play
whatever this is
king's gambit
um i usually play this as black so
[Music]
try and figure out the
way to play this for white
i do have to move quickly
because i still want to have a minute
left like going into endgame as a plan
where did sally go during the bombing
is that a boss or um not a boss a joke
or a genuine question
everywhere oh that's kind of
i get the joke but
yeah we can get some colon
apple d's in the chat
uh let's try and
keep a clear mind here
knights vs bishops
okay so i went back the pawn
i mean there's a lot of pressure
i think it's okay
87 queen e7 i guess queen d2
always have to watch out for this stuff
okay i don't mind the queen train
get my knight to d5 now
good
just gotta
eat through the end game
maybe there's b5
rookie four
my king is slightly better pawns are
slightly better it's equal material but
i'm going to try and play this for a win
despite the time situation
trying to calculate the
pawn ending after that
might as well
i think boxing the means looks long
after h64
there's b5 though
what i take
okay now it's
perpetual zug
we'll get plenty of time
because once this pawn is lost it's
pretty clear when
i wonder if i can win this without going
below 10
seconds okay
mission accomplished let's go
hey extra typo gifting to rka
okay
got the job done there
77 lucky number
yeah king pawn endings are tricky
sometimes it comes down to
who runs out of moves first
playing anonymous warrior
so this time i'll play a london and
berserk
okay not entirely sure about this
opening but looks kind of fun
uh
what is this
he won
okay this will be a bit more positional
probably preserve the bishop
take that
the problem for black is i control b8
we might see knight g3
or not play b4
and now i preserve the bishop
so
um
i'm not better here
i want to walk the king to f2
and the king pawn engine is winning
b6 is now tender
[Music]
this is objectively a draw
okay lock kind of over push though
let's go okay
oh heart rate went up there
got the job done though
breath
let's fall below 100
no don't increase
110
good workout
68th place
pretty nice
never played this opponent before
playing e6
i think i just want to try and play
something solid
like bishop d6
i'll admit i don't
entirely know much theory here but
this looks playable
oh goodbye to pam thanks for being here
i take taken this move
it looks fun
oh wait no it just loses a pawn
okay i guess i can take first
and then win this pawn for free
snake with a rook or knight
with a rook
and take him in this pawn
up two pawns now
i wanted to play h5 and then knight h5
and maybe i'll go for that
we got some end game where i'm still up
a pawn
congratulations takes takes
and we trade on g5
the first sneeze of the marathon
this position is nothing to sneeze at
thanks for blessing me
i feel so blessed now
i kind of have to sneeze again
thanks for the salud bits
i think that knight has to return to c3
might as well optimize my king
okay i'm threatening sneaky things
wow so there i mean there is a double
threat i can play knight e3 or
x on c2
uh
maybe 93 is better
keep the rook on the board
and e3 can be weak later
let's go okay four hours and two minutes
and some seconds left
sixty-two
i think i'm on top 50.
taking a risk here
was working against chris
good luck
a grand prix attack time
good luck i can't play d3
play this move
thank you
type numbers
also thank you lockheed back with the w
bits
okay i just want the castle
slightly unusual position
okay but now it's a dream position i
mean this is what every
positional player dreams of
it's still going to take work though
uh knight b6 is coming
time is ticking
it's actually not so clear
move back and maneuver the knight
my bishop didn't want to be on a3
i gotta move a lot quicker here
the plan i want to go for is h3g4 come
on eric
i'm trying i'm trying
bishop i just moved back
if we trade then i'll have bishop a5 as
a threat
idea king h2 or g1 h4h5
really
can take your first and then be up a
piece
now there's a pin i'm writing bishop for
hey it's john what's up john
hey guys
it's eric
appreciate the rage on
if you're just joining i berserk this
game
i'm trying to win i have a strong pin
my name is not finn
or finns
uh can i take this
i think i can take that
discovered attack
also thing a fork
was john playing the marathon too
actually i have no time to look at chat
i got to focus
so it takes high fork on jake's is
expected
if night moves i fork like this
debating whether take with rooker bishop
i'll be rook
but maybe bishop
yeah
there's no time to be indecisive
okay creating the battery
um
take back
i might want to go for this
let's go for the massaging of the dark
squares
[Music]
when in doubt
act like a masseuse
okay i need to take the pawn
oh no my rook
oh no
ah my rook is still hanging
please take it
please
oh no my queen ah
okay check me
oh that's a fun finish
yeah dark squares are really
massageable
[Music]
okay
back to tournaments
shout out to john i think we have a john
command
you tree ropper
okay let's play something solid mop is
working this game
is everything so stressful sometimes
i think you lockheed or w bits
yeah this is a slightly offbeat line i
like to play against king's indian
i keep the pawn back on c7
and usually go for this some a4 idea
maybe a3 idea
but the rook on d8s and this is all very
standard for the setup
d3 is a bit weak
it seems like a square white should
control but there's some light before
maybe at some point
also consider taking
i also consider this maneuver
it leaves g7 as kind of an open target
but
i have bishop f8 if i need it
i'm dreaming of some position where i
just get a knight to d3
like a weak square it's just something
that's easy to attack
and perhaps a bit difficult for the
opponent to defend
also maybe threatening to take
and just win a pawn
if i played this or it'd be
it's easier play for white
you can see two night here and then here
attacks things i have this move
after queen z2 i might play bishop f8
just prophylactic measures
that was unexpected
this does defend the pawn
and take and maybe win this thing
throwing a3
oh there's some funny lines
i think i'll start with or what am i
doing let's start with knight c6 takes
e4
start with this
and then this
it seems risky but i don't see how it
punishes me
i have queen here i just move back
and offer the trade of bishops
up a decent amount of time
yeah if only knights could move like
bishops
i would have a battery
okay so i have this move
maybe the only move this
let's play this
now i have the bishop here
which is very pleasant
possibility of uh
x in bishop f6
i think i'll just play h5
a solid position
take and then take
having a hard time assessing that
position i think it looks good though
first case i have bishop six but
i think the plans to take
and then just
say bishop f6 for next move
the bishops are going to be really
powerful
the problem for light is after the rook
moves i take
and then i'm controlling the queening
square with the bishop
there's even icing on the cake bishop b1
not even queen but just
ensure the queen can't be taken
had a good sleep smile
yeah sleep was good i think i slept from
like eight something to one something
so
five something hours
and these tournaments do kind of throw
my sleeping schedule off probably not
the healthiest but
they're still fun
okay so now i'm up a bishop
made queens
keep things simple
lockheed with the early w bits
and this should be pretty
straightforward
one can't be defended
okay
pretty clean game
i can't complain with that one almost
top 50 i mean top 50 was my goal for
like the five hours but
i might have to make a new goal
[Music]
playing a fellow ion
uh
three things
i like free things
still want to stay focused
and keep my composure
um
in here i do queen g3
wow
okay i don't mind trading stuff
uh
to do this
in here
i'm up a full piece
just gotta keep the pace
i blundered
not exactly what i wanted
okay blackbanders back
let's go
okay
it was not the highest quality game
but it was a game
i'm on a nice streak
i've been berserking every other game
this time i want berserk
i played this opponent last night a bit
oh did i have this game i had knight g4
last night after which queen d2
i had a game last night where i hung my
queen after e5
um i remember looking at this line
i'm supposed to take
he takes an f3
recall i'm supposed to play positionally
it's the benefit of studying
my games i play is that
like if i didn't study that game last
night i would have
kind of just been on my own
okay now it looks like a nice position
probably still some idea to push the h
pawn
g4 h5
in combination with this too
king h8 i mean
black is feeling the heat
i think i'll play g4
make the pawn smile
ah that was idea
okay i mean h5 is still on the
horizon
wow
you kind of want to play h6
alpha zero style preventing black from
playing h6
now all i need to do is get a pawn to g7
easier said than done
i would prefer it to be easier done than
said but
sometimes that's not how things work
a move
wondering if i can just sack
sack upon
because after takes takes takes or
diagonals open
um
yeah that looks pleasant
also obstructing the rook from defending
the knight so
might be threatening to win
here i'll take with bishop
let's defend now
queen still attacked
a7 is randomly hanging i don't think i
want to take it though because
broke8
uh so what else to do
queen c3
c5
queen c5 is interesting
i mean there's lines where black tries
to win a2 i have b3 we trade
i think i have to take with bishop
keep the rook defending the pawn
that's a move
yeah it's about to get positional
unless i don't go for the queen trade
which actually yeah let's keep queens on
the board
this is king is more checkmateable
speak with bishop
i could take with brooke but
he was bishop
this is a possible move now but
not happening
there should be two i have not a five
i do want to keep the pawn here
it's kind of annoying my rook being
stuck but
i called for
okay i'm allowing some trades
uh this could get very positional
oh i'm losing the pawn
a pawn is my baby
i have this move
but doesn't look right
i have this move
i'm going for a counter attack
maybe queen e6 ideas
in combination with this create the
battery
this pawn is also hanging
so c5 bishop c4 takes i just take takes
and mate
oh
i kind of forgot about that move
move all the way back
there's a funny line to
let's play queen a3 here
and the queen is a little bit overworked
and probably threatening just to take or
even
not threatening rook team one
also threatening the pawn these are my
two threats
and the rook's kind of pinned
black would want to play that move
okay now i'm winning two pawns
for the price of one
feels like walmart
i don't even know if walmart has those
deals
uh
a2 falls
it's not so clear if i take on b6
this move is cleaner
it gets kind of
murky i want to play b3 if i got the
chance
okay got the chance
preparing this e5 is very logical
[Music]
play this move
idea bishop c4
i value peace activity more than pawns
uh
ooh
be careful here queen e3 was a threat
this is getting tricky
also getting really low on time
okay rook has done its job on the h file
trade i guess we trade
i can't do that i was about to wander my
queen
the ship was pinned
and play this move
somehow defending
you winning
one scares me though
crazy game
my c pawn
let's go
the breakthrough with g5
oh no my rook
and what a game i took efforts
got the job done though
i think i was in trouble
uh there's a move
i think just h3 here
like how do i stop the pawn
i think i was just completely losing
thank you lockheed
it's a lot of w's in a row
44th place
oh what's my new goal
trying to reach top
30 how about
that should be accomplishable
i'm only berserking if my opponent works
but i'll still play aggressively
i have to play aggressively against the
london
i supposed to take
i'll admit i
don't know this line so well i assume
i'm just supposed to take back and
get a playable position
okay
white's going to go for e4
this is probably some sort of theory
looks okay though
is he forcing this move
yeah already a nice opening
hmm
i'm gonna go for 94 soon
f3
is a move
defending the
queen there's d4 maybe h5
trying to make gradual improvements
27
so there's no pin
my apon's been hanging for a while
do i care
i kind of care maybe this move
align with the king defend the pawn
trying to use my h-pawn like that
previous game
yes
oh yes thank you matt
clubbing for half a year
only wants to get knight c5 in
of a5
i think i go for h3 here
the pawn will just chill the pond might
fall but
it'll perish a hero
it's very committal i give away the d4
square
i'm trying to
induce light square weaknesses
going after the pawn
i'm getting bishop f3
i'll go for a5
temporary ponzac
it takes i have rook here
the problem for white a3 i take and the
knights hanging
now there's no more knight c5
i might get the two for one deal again i
gave away one pawn
and very likely both these pawns will
fall
i would love to teleport my queen to h1
i have to build a teleportation machine
new chess strategy
wait
taken the knights trapped
i mean there's this move
oh there's that move oh very fancy
um i think i'll
got my two for one deal
now bishop g2
oh but ah it's kind of a fork
oh white was very clever there
so probably queen c5
if i want to pressure c2
the vent of takes takes queen f2
uh probably go for the double up
there's king f2
maybe queen c4
is here and queen e4 queen g2
yeah white's a bit stuck here
both this and this are tied down to the
c2 pawn
this is a pin
wow e4 i want to move
f3 is no longer a threat
we'll maybe
do that
i'm so confused
here think i want to play rook a3
they work on c3 also defend the pawn
kind of
if rookie 3 i take
takes like when the pawn queen digs out
in the pawn
okay one i play this
and then this and this are prevented
also maybe threading uh to do this
difficult position for white
that's a move
uh
we need three
i need this move
just preventing rookie three
bonds are meant to be pushed
also can kind of just build a
nice
architecture formation
a very solid foundation
so yeah things defend each other which
is nice
white's being resourceful though
close to my opponent
uh
this move
wow
oh my queen
hop in there
blunder the queen the white didn't take
it
better be winning
i think this is winning i should have
been losing though
oh draw
these pawns are
invincible
go
yo i think white had multiple ways to
win too
there was queen g5 at many points
oh what a game
could have easy lost that f6 was a very
strong move
the problem
and i played queen c4 i think queen g5
is already tough game
uh but then i just wondered my queen
but then white didn't take it white
still has queen g5
okay i was very fortunate there
the streak continues 276.
okay
his opponent has beat me twice
i've only won him once
no berserking
thank you lockheed thank you alpha m
staffer gambit no staffer gambit
uh i'll play this line
other night or yesterday i had the line
takes in bishop d5 bishop v4
xbishop f7 crazy crazy line
okay with this
have to try and remember my theory
i'm already kind of forgetting
a few weeks ago i like spent an hour
trying to learn these lines
it's hard to keep them remembered if
i'm not practicing them
um
i mean this is clearly an idea
considering some
queen h4
looks weird but
i'm preventing the queen from coming to
h5
enabling moves like bishop g4
mcqueen's not so easy to remove like g3i
of queen h3
might be some weird like queen
a4
winging
maneuver
that's kind of a cool move
work
i have to play c6
it's kind of sad if it works wow i think
it works
i mean
oh that's so sad
like a castle
i think i just castle here and
beat down a couple pawns
there's still practical chances because
uh it's office car bishops
of course this is not what i wanted
i'm basically just playing for
a draw
this move
b6 is playable maybe start with b6
there's a three is coming though
d81
okay
so i'm down two pons i mean white
structure is a bit weak so
maybe i can win a pawn back
i mean all these pawns are potential
weaknesses
get the bishop here we threatening
bishop b4
my queen oh no thankfully i've i've
avoided blundering a queen
i think pawns are easier to blunder than
the queen
um yeah i don't think i want a queen
train
f4 might be coming
there is this move
followed by ruxiate
brook t1 rock d4
[Music]
okay
i would love to just get some attack
that would require lifting rooks
do i even rook lift pro
i mean if i get a rook to g4 it doesn't
matter
how many pawns i'm down if i'm mating
time is also dwindling for both of us
i'm playing the person in sixth place
they probably
they're probably sleep deprived
which is somewhat
helpful for me
i'm gonna go after this pawn
crazy they have almost 400 tournament
points
okay tickling this pawn
um
[Music]
i can induce g3
now i want to get bishop d5 in
maybe just b5
times low 2
h5
here
here we go
almost didn't see my rook was attacked
e3 doesn't work
doesn't work
this move first
there we go
let's go okay come on i won that
ah i was just worse off the opening
middle game but came back
i got the rook lifting in
worked out
only got low on time
okay top 40
i'm trying to reclaim my 2600 rating
i'm only down 83 points this tournament
okay
the win streak continues thank you
lockheed
thank you herb gourd
appreciate the bits
yeah we'll go into
this typical line in london
um
not entirely sure what i'm doing here i
think i'll just chill and wait for an
opportunity to strike
b4 is probably not called for
bishop here
i'm just chilling
rookie 2
i'm kind of tempted to take the palm
it's really not called for though
there's knight here
be rookie two first or uh rook d1
play rookie 2.
we're solving standard deviation
offering a nitrate
uh queen b1
[Music]
c1
i want to massage the dark squares
before maybe coming
clearing um
[Music]
start with uh with this
got my battery if the light moves i
could consider taking the rook
i want to play bishop h6
yeah i'm getting kind of positionally
portrayed here
by
not too many good looking options either
i mean there's rook c1
unpleasant though takes
i'm banking on rookie 3 working i think
does it work
might work
this is still really unpleasant
you human bot person
first time prime sub
interesting
uh
i kind of have to take
over this
i mean there's a line jake's takes aches
knight g5
small hoop
wow
they can play bishop d4
also play knight t4 but
let's try this
ooh interesting
i have queen d4 as well
i'm probably just going to be losing a
pawn though fortunately
maybe queen d4 offers me the best
chances
there's also this move
[Music]
let's try this
it's not pretty
it's really not pretty
eggs
desperately trying to stay alive here
play c4
at least we simplified
i won't be blundering my queen
this pawn could be a
weakness
i just want to bring the king into d2
that's not looking good
oh very clever i took the knight there
was rook czech knight 91 and e2
hi
also quack also hi
also
swag also quack
welcome back
oh my knight
i win the pawn i'm not resigning
ending this
it's very resignable though
but you never know
oh i got forked i'll
yeah this uh
where was it
where was it
oh yeah rook takes a5 was very uh very
nice
his takes check here here i lose
okay what to do there goes my streak i
was on a 13-game win streak
um
i'm out of
my streak and out of tea
oh no
should boil more water
okay
approaching the three hour
three hour left mark
been live for almost two hours
the sound might be a little bit weird
for the next
minute or so
um
thank you fish houses
new sub at tier one
okay
trying to get some compensation
oh that was notification sound from me
chess yeah
st louis chess club is starting their
their classes
um i'll play this move
i'm down the pawn but okay i have more
activity
interesting central pressure
it's time for a throat comfort tea
roach comfort
take this
[Music]
actually not sure what my threat is here
maybe just to
gradually increase pressure
okay here i can
take and play f6
or even
what's the best way to do this
okay i have to start with by taking
you can also take here
i was using f6 and then
c3
if i move the knight there's queen c4
ah
i think i'll just take here
it looks like a slightly better
end game after this we
trade and then i get the rook to the
second
and maybe the other up to the second two
oh i was about to
drink tea without the tea bag
find a tea bag that's my last tea bag oh
no
box is empty
i have to find new ways to comfort my
throat
when will you hire a personal servant i
hear this is common among godlike
celebrities also quack also quack also
quack
the first step is hiring a a butler duck
just quack at me
also is this just a draw
this might just be a draw
which would be kind of sad
i have this move
[Music]
you fish house gifting five appreciate
that
i'll be so sad if this is actually a
draw
i think i start with this
and rook here and then this maybe
there's room to play for a win
i'm up upon
just trying to keep upon
um
g6 or h5
h5
now g6
[Music]
i should probably just agree to a draw
frankie brooks on the board
what is your max viewer record
across ten thousand one
and carl rated me like 20 000 people
wait that doesn't make sense
i think her car rated me like 10k and
then
it briefly crossed 10 000.
either of us are playing for a draw
it's time to draw
or is it
it looks like a really simple end game
my rook here i think is losing
i was about to play this and
first
go eric
i'm offering a draw
i don't think there's a way for white to
actually win the pawn
or is there
i may have over pushed a little bit if i
lose this it's so bad
oh no
i'm losing this i put my king on the
wrong square
oh no
i lost both my pawns
that's so sad
i feel so broken right now
i guess that's why you should always
play on i got way too long time this
game too
you'll have to try
yeah there's no stalemate tricks
unfortunately uh
oh it's so sad
okay
awesome so me and the man are supposed
to play a game soon where i play the
mayonnaise gambit any tips oh
um eat a lot of mayonnaise
i think that's the only way to play the
gambit you just have to
load up on mayo
i'll make it i'll make the gambit more
strong
okay let's uh
let's try and rebound
46th place
no berserking
no more playing on drawn positions
this is supposed to be pleasant
in queen g4 and go for the h pawn bush
okay this pond's a little bit weak
it might fall
i do still play g4
oh
okay i have an idea to
hmm
let's play more positionally
i think about taking but black has a
bishop here
don't want to open the position too much
this bishop is really sad
i might go for this lift
and g6 is one of the main targets
and we trade
yeah so trading bishop for night now i
have the dark squares in my control
i mean black might go for the exchange
sack the bishop here i have rook d1
interesting
i want to put the rook on g5
the question is how to crack the
position
maybe rook g5 queen g3
i'm kind of abandoning the queen side
it's interesting
maybe this and e4 at some point
and open things up a bit
uh
do i defend the pawn
nah
okay so i was running rook h5
black kinda sought
so i'm losing a pawn the thing is pawns
are not as relevant as meaning
now e4
i would love to open the e file but
probably not going to happen
[Music]
another idea to take takes in e6 finding
the rook with the bishop
as a goal position
anything can happen
all three results are possible
if i take
there's kind of a funny line
maybe i would take your first
give block the choice of blundering
[Music]
wow
okay
i mean i was going to take here and then
it would be easy for black to take back
but
yeah that's uh that's nice
hey
it's a shock
i think that's a german chest streamer
thanks for the raid
178's welcome everyone
oh no
[Music]
if you're just joining this is a the
autumn marathon tournament
i am in 46th place
oh i'm playing a username probably
referring to among us
so i played the
the tournament last night
for almost 10 hours straight
and i've been playing for last two or so
hours
opponent wants to hurt me
i'm thinking of this move is kind of
interesting
also just castle and deep brave
94 bishop b7
it doesn't look pretty but
i'm staying alive
oh thank you lockheed i did win that
previous game
very abruptly
okay
opponent really wants to hurt me
if i play d5 i mean d5 would be the way
to go
there's a funny looking line like takes
takes f5 and then queen a5
that's probably not good for me but what
else to do
there's also d5 immediately
aches and then takes and it's a fork
maybe playable
i'm just trying to weather the storm get
a playable position
thank you corbin884
first time prime sub
yeah for those unaware because i know
there's a lot of new viewers here
if you have amazon prime you can
subscribe for free
we have the prime command
easy way to support the channel
okay so i have a pawn for a night
it looks like i'm winning back something
or i'm getting mated
or not is queen b6 yeah very key move
and then i'll take and i win the bishop
think you chill chest and create another
first time prime sub
oh interfere
i should remind people to sub with prime
more often
uh
takes maybe
there's also queen a5
devious move
we have enrico
timing for four months
i still have to be careful just optical
our bishop situation
[Music]
g6 would be
really bad for me
but things look stable it's nice being
up a pawn
i was the one trying to play again at
this game
thank you oven us real
[Music]
loving with prime for nine months
opponent wants to play bishop d4
maybe rook d8
keeping tension
there's a funny line
i don't think it's good the bishop d4 g5
try and divert the queen away from
defending the bishop
more likely bishop d4 i would play rook
d5 to lift the rook
attack g2
it's wool
maybe queen h5
e7 is undefended there
or maybe a6
but bishop h6 is coming which is kind of
scary
i think i'll play this
give up the pawn and then go for just
very quick attack
yo yo yo speedy milk
low vib zz
ua2 r2p2
yeah i guess white's okay here
unless i have this move even this move
is playable within rook f1
oh i guess queen d1
quinty one might be the best move
oh no there's bishop g1 in that
but maybe that's still fine for me
it's still okay for me
so if takes takes here takes here
yeah that should be winning
otherwise if rook f1 immediately i have
this
now i have the battery
rook c1 i take on e2
of rook fc1 not happening
okay so brief calculation check here it
takes them bishop d5 so it should be
winning
might as well make some luft
i want to play rook g4 very soon
also don't want to flag
this pawns hanging
oh
luft oh no
just plunder up
i blundered another
ah my position what happened to my
position
oh
ah
i was completely winning too
i just had to not blender stuff
i guess this was a good move
i saw this rook was attacked
i had to play like queen c2 or something
also there was a moment i think here
rooks you want i know not
maybe before maybe here
no everything was fine
until it wasn't fine
i do
oh no my everything
thank you ruckles subbing with prime
oh man
let's try and stay in the top 50.
okay just have to save august
tilting
move
why did i do that
okay maybe i will go full tilt and stack
everything and hopefully it's means
yeah this is working out
wasn't fully intended
oh no my rook
there we go
c
let's go okay i want to gain
i just got berserking win too
okay i'm trying to back on the win
streak
playing koke fisher from chile
very positional english
i'm gonna play f5
thank you lockheed
i'll try and rack up some more w bits at
some point
x takes
we'll take
uh
play this
now we're trading a lot
that's roughly equal
i'm trying to induce some weaknesses
always easy
probably bishop g6
taking queen h5
not sure if this accomplishes much
though
before he's not really a threat
is it is
your queen c2
okay going into the end game
e5 maybe just d5 not what i wanted but
i know what i had to do
well the night wants to be here
take some time to get there
listen this is a plan
play g5
it takes an a5
[Music]
um
i just want the pasade pawn
i want to miss c6 there which they've
been troublesome
in a little bit of trouble
i have two outside passwords
slightly surprisingly
i have no time
final position
i'm still might be losing but i had
drawing chances
to do
berserking's risky
maybe i'd like i shouldn't be berserk i
should just play quickly and keep the
increment
you'll try and play aggressively
okay london time
mainline london
i'll admit i don't know if i'm playing
theory but
i'm threatening to win in one move so
looks interesting
uh i think black just blunder the fork
this move
maybe c4
i'll take and then play c4
i'm giving back upon
okay
this is pleasant because
an endgame should be a pretty routine
win
of course you never know
these positions take work
i have f3 here
maybe just b3
give the g pawn back and
go after this thing
that's a greedy move but
free food
thank you john's vibing today
appreciate the bits
oh these pawns are vibing
yeah this is far from clear
maybe f3
even f4 is interesting
because g5 of queen c7
thinks i take
those palms defended thankfully
yeah not easy to find a
good looking move for black
that's a move
um
i mean i think i just play this and
and defend
i mean rook f8
i broke g6 i take and rook f2
oh
[Music]
there's e2
i take on c6
so something like uh
it should be okay like rook c2
[Music]
it looks kind of scary but
hopefully it's okay
maybe rook b2
[Music]
ah rook c2
defending from a distance
it's crazy like
not clear how i defend
maybe this
d4 is a threat
i don't want to allow perpet
23 is also a threat
i might have to settle for a draw that's
crazy
plus i'm missing something but
i think i have to settle for a draw
also i want to go really insane and play
for win x takes
f1
good morning
playable
i think i just play this
settle for
most black wants to play on
i'm going to draw
was it a draw the whole time let's see
yeah oh rookie choose my only drawing
move oh that's crazy why isn't maybe
some small trouble
wow so this whole line is drawn
uh i had to play rook ae1 first
prepare rook f2 and not allow e3
yeah tough game
okay
yeah trying to stay in the top 50. it's
not easy
playing mata
[Music]
the humidor
uh b3
e5 might be justified
let's just castle
i might just slow play this like b6
etcetera
i'm generally happy with these uh these
structures it's kind of like a reverse
kali
maybe my point was attempting to play
something collie-like
but
it seems like black is getting the
better version of this
consider taking
x and kg2
[Music]
go after f2
yeah the knight wants to come here
i can still consider taking
let's start with this
okay that's kind of what i wanted
now these pawns are tender
looks like i can win a pawn
the light squares are also weak
maybe bishop c8
be careful how i do this
i could also
let's just take
a pawn
one's playing really quickly
uh
get the bishop back in play
play this
live
get the rook to that file
d4 looks interesting
i don't think i can resist
else i can
f5
i'll play h6 g5
i'll play d4
trying to make progress
i might end up stacking actually
fancy move
or
want to play e3
there's a funny line
i think i'll start with this move
ideas after takes i just play rook c8
threatening made in two main three
it's not so easy for white to defend
there's not here but then d3
if king here i still go for this
is this
there's also that
oh does it get funnier
i think this is winning
the problem for a white is a knight
can't take because
it's pinned to the square now i take
here
or this happens and
i guess i still have to fight on
uh how do i save the bishop
this doesn't work because brook takes
there's this move
check
at some point i should make a looft
just a matter of when and how
it is first
and this should be a pretty
straightforward win okay now i'm trying
this
wondering did white have rook f3 there
why not rook off three
like oh i take with check okay
okay that was nice
moving on
still top 50.
i got a win
trying to build a streak
yeah top 30 will be difficult
two hours and 20 minutes left
i got into top 50 a while ago
it was working taking a risk
so really got to stay focused here
h3 first
we're gonna have a
quieter lunging system
okay going for f4 f5 yeah the point of
berserking um it guarantees a game won't
last super long
and it it's an attempt to
rack up more tournament points
of course there's risk
but it forces me to play more
aggressively
i've been going back and forth
okay i want to go for f4 f5
c4 is under control so is b5
box not going to take here
i think now
maybe g4
restricting any knight move
and probably want to bring
all the pieces to the party
hmm
it's starting with this hitting the pawn
trying to make black commit to something
now work f6
b5 is probably coming
[Music]
maybe this move
so if takes takes king h a queen h6 rook
g8 g5 i think is winning
this idea of workout for queen h7 right
h4 mates
of course there's that
uh might as well take
the rook back first
now the minority attack still exists for
black
but i have some nice f file action
i'd like to play h5 soon
defend creating the gun
uh
to do this
kind of a lot queen g5
g5 rook g3
[Music]
oh no queen g5 i take the thing
block's a bit tied down
knights completely nevermind
play this move first
wow
okay so if it takes g5 queen g3
it should be winning now
we're gonna play out uh queen queen and
bishop versus two rooks
h6 to include
the block's getting low on time but
black has this increment
i don't
there we go just have to force a queen
trade
foreign
let's go okay
let's go
yeah holy heck with the ombudson let's
go
so
yeah if i didn't berserk i would get two
points but because i berserked i get
three points for that one
so one step closer to
300 tournament points
oh we drew earlier
oh we had a crazy game earlier okay why
was white that game
nothing crazy here
just gonna try and play positionally
f4 is coming let's play this
slightly unsettling
probably not a great position
i want to do this and this
i'm feeling the strain
it hurts a little bit
back is sore
okay uh
d5 is coming
i'll play this
it's not exactly what i want but
okay staying alive
the center gets locked then
i think there's some c5
ideas maybe this move
just dying the pawn
there's also the possibility of this
maneuver knight f8 to g6
okay i'm happy with the c file
i felt like that helped me more than
helped white
i was more expecting e5 eventually
let's play a5
now the idea to double up
so this idea
let's start with this
even this
this pawn's weak
i win the pawn i get a pass a pawn
well not only wants to go for the attack
i can take my time with winning the pawn
i want to go for this and just
maybe trade off
and now
i'll win the pawn
bishop b5 is now a threat
and so is the pawn now hanging
thinking this crazy move
i think i have to give away the pawn
maybe this
idea to sneak in
i have this move
the rook is intruding
and the pieces are ready to pounce
kind of
i don't think this works
range 4 there's bishop g3
x doesn't work maybe i just start
pushing
house pawns are meant to be
pushed in close to queening
keep pushing
i have this move
also take
there's a funny line right you can then
take on g4
doesn't work though
take
bishop
i have this move
this
and there's bishop g3 though
maybe it's worth playing
idea
and queen's coming to a1
[Music]
i have six seconds left
best time management
oh my pawn
i'm
still trying to fight
yeah
that's a good move too
everything's hanging it just attacks
everything
have any chance was that game
i felt like i had chances with the past
apon
um
yeah at some point it was roughly
balanced
at some point better for me
instead of
[Music]
rook e8 bishop
b7 ah this should be seven brook eight
and i keep the pawn
okay
it's tough
work so hard to like try and win a game
and lose
but life goes on
playing parkour
i don't think this player berserks
oh this player i beat out of opening
that one game
[Music]
uh yeah they went into some londons
eat them twice with the london
okay london number three
b5 i prepared a b5 against fiddler
prepared the move
c4
there's a funny line uh we trade and
then e6
e5 queen b3 is kind of cool
[Music]
still queen b3
only wants to do this
did this move
um
it's okay to allow knight a5
okay there's some c file pressure and
the setup's a little bit awkward for
black
question is what to do with this bishop
i kind of want to play d5 here
there's also a bishop g5
e5
because in the event of takes i take
with queen
x takes i hit the bishop in the pawn and
this is also tender
there's also line takes
x takes
x takes
i don't think leads to much for me
oh add phosphate this opponent too good
job at fast
i've never really gotten into parkour
but my queen is about to do some parkour
across the board
wow
[Music]
that looks really
bad for black but i don't see a way to
punish it
i don't want to take too much time here
i think i'll play
you know
get this move
oh this move looks nice
i think it works too
the problem for a blog if pawn takes i
play this
if bishop takes
i take and still play knight d5
and the queen is basically trapped
i think
there's some beautiful lines with um
yeah so 95 now
want to play knight c6 but then i would
take on e7
now d7 hangs
there is knight c6
here not quite over
i've queen for rook and knight
don't want my queen to get trapped
[Music]
yo chat let's get some hype spam them
emotes
ah
all
all people must obey teotwaki
thanks to twaki
yeah let's get some energy i need to
feed on
the energy of the emotes
also this game is far from over
hey it's email only mode
oh no wait i have this move
okay
this is not gonna be easy to win
in black is still potentially playing
for a win too
probably a four first
there's
i guess there's this
trade
or we don't trade
quack quack quack quack quack quack
quack also
thanks quack that
oh i don't know what to do here
i think i'll just play
i'll play this
revoke h5 maybe go for g4 actually
some idea
i want to quack but see how
do this move
yeah okay
green's a little bit out of play
oh that would blunder
this one's actually really difficult
for h4 and work off two
and here i guess
i'm in trouble here
doesn't work
get this
also this
little quack
my king will find a nice pocket on g3
i think rox c8
might be
ending with the king
covering up four
i want to get the queen in somehow
this now
so
thing made in two
bishop three it's made in three one
two
three
count to three let's go
let's go
also quack
yeah don't mess with the
quacking
man that was terrifying i almost got
mated
but then i was the one who made it so
it's all good
i think the goal is just to stay in top
50. it's tough
a lot of people are trying to
catch up to me
oh playing spicy food
let's eat some spicy food
i'd be this player yesterday
i think berserking too
uh let's be careful
and the spicy food is so delicious right
now
and so spicy
uh
as positions so so spicy
but it's a good kind of spicy
this is force mate
it might be
i'm threatening queen f8 mate
no need to castle
let's go
eat some spicy food
47th place
oh i'm playing the fastest man alive
berserk
okay i think the bizarre pack
if they don't i'll be disappointed
i'm so disappointed
ah how do i play the fastest man alive
and they're not even
berserking back
wait what am i doing
we're playing a scotch playing a scotch
i don't play the scotch
we're gonna have enochmanson
oh this line let's play knight g7
new theory
b7
[Music]
this is some sort of theory
i lost his line the other day it was my
d7 move
very tricky
okay i think i have to play c6
and life goes on i'll sing this about
six ideas
out of the bishop here
and i'm giving the fastest man alive
time odds
that's a bad decision
at least i have a plan to get my king
safe and bishop f6
i just want to skewer stuff
queen a4 i have to be ready for
a4
bishop g5 of f6
probably 284 bishop d7
oh there's queen c52
then bishop e6
it's important to stay focused on my
opponent's turn
i wouldn't mind some trading
who's meeting
oh no my bishop
i think at the very least i win the pawn
mission d4 is not a threat
this is the candidate move
i'll make some luft
maybe now bishop g5
let's save the thing ooh
take
back
be very careful here he's coming
and we'll play f6
i'm losing back the punchline
yeah it's going to be hard to
deal with this
even the time situation
um
to sneak in
[Music]
vermont good move
trouble
i don't have any defense
eg5
so sad
okay
it's tough good game though
i liked my position until i didn't like
my position
opponent was fast
or are they the fastest man alive i
don't know
okay no berserking let's get a
king's gambit
upon i haven't played the ponziani at
this tournament
i don't think
okay i'll play my my main line sicilian
stuff
yeah this is a kind of interesting
sideline
i think black is
already in a lot of trouble here
i have three attackers
one day five attackers
okay that feels good
10 move win
opponent didn't want to suffer
oh i was -4 oh i was
completely winning in the previous game
[Music]
well it's kind of sad
it's nice to have a game like that as
always thanks for the great content
oh thank you love hs
something for 34 months
welcome back
yeah people played 93 to get a knight f4
that's why i played knight g6
let me go for this too
let's get the bishop hair
and castle
i might go for the the typical budapest
rook lift
maybe your new mask would grant you
newfound strength energy and powers
about to sign off soon
good luck for the end of the tournament
chat
hype now
okay
time for hype
also time not to flag
i have to play with incredible
perfection not to lose this
also white almost has a pawn cube
also quack
okay so the pawns defended i want to
play this
also thank you teotwaki
i appreciate the words
and the support
and the modding
now let's go after the night
hey eric have a great day unfortunately
i got my discord account stolen this
morning i hope you didn't get a lot of
spam by user spazzer on your discord i'm
so sad i hope i can get it restored
shortly but i don't count on it less
than three
oh yeah make sure your passwords are
strong use the password manager
uh what to do g6
i have no time
and no clue what i'm doing
g6 looks really bad but i guess i play
it
here i play this
g7 may have been missed there
it's still really unpleasant for me
my my rook lifted to the wrong location
[Music]
i'm about to be xbones
still a small ounce of hope
oh no
oops
it's not looking good
i can maybe win the pawn
i was really hoping for roxy sat in
there
i resign good game opponent played well
what to do
okay
i do need a break soon one more game
then break time
i'll try and recover
nobody's working this time
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it was hard to play aggressively against
this
h3
yeah so very typical london setup
bishop g2 or bishop h2
box playing some typical ideas
after this pawn
e6 i take on d6
oh my g pawns hanging i have this move
accidental gambit
i know what's happening now i mean
there's h6
yeah this is probably good for black
at least it's playable
e5
getting some bononi structure
the queen's i need for some reason
i want to go after the pawn eventually
i can take
knight
knight e4 is kind of funny
i'll play rook g1 first
pony 24 is so anti-positional though
h2
h1
f2 i'm playing f2
3 is tender
might make sense just to take
maybe i should play king h2
there's a bishop f1
and
okay i don't think i mind a queen trade
down the pawn that
have some central space
off the car bishops
at some point i think black will have to
play this or this
yeah i thought i could just do this
i guess we're just trading
[Music]
and i lose this pawn
lock defends in the end
that's interesting
have this move
bishop e2
it's far from over though i'm still down
upon
my idea to do this and this
give this one move
i want to bring the bishop to c6 play
rook b1 and then win the pawn
i was not sure how i got the bishop in
hoping for bishop c7
what happening
picking on d3 perhaps
oh the bishop's gonna hug my rook with
it
uh oh
i don't like this feeling
of getting hugged
the e5 and bring the king in
do i on passant probably not
reserve the idea of e6
what does this position
brick me
i play this move and then this will just
have this move
or in this move
start with this
only way to defend the pawn is king h6
that's a counter attack
[Music]
this is probably bad for me
oh wait a minute it's a free pawn
it's probably good for me
what am i talking about
let's take a free pawn
i escaped the bear hug with a bishop hug
one inch forgot
okay now i have h4
i have this move too
the funny looking move
this is this
or this and this
yeah boxing trouble
if takes is made in two
are made in three
the center pawns are so strong here
okay time to
i take her
a time to take
secure
maybe it's not quite mating
it's close though
uh
play this
i assume this is a force made threat
let's go
okay taking a small break
uh i'll be back
momentarily
all's a tournament
12 months of love for you enjoying being
a part of your journey got to see it
through my boy thank you mr kilo welcome
back
happy one year
okay i'll be back momentarily in the
meantime
watch a game
between some of the top players
i'll be back soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
back to tournament
92 minutes left wow
it's almost over
i'm barely holding on to top 50.
it's tough
there's some people paused
playing light like
i'll play one game with the music
there's a setting on the chess
it generates sounds based on the
game
oh no not this line
actually i don't mind that
there's a better bishop c4 there
[Music]
[Music]
i blunder
i may have blundered
unless i can take
maybe it's okay
[Music]
it might not be okay but
we'll find out soon
it's the sound setting sound and then
pentatonic
i know it's cut off but
that's a nice feature
i could take here
so i'm temporarily down a piece but
i'll win something back
maybe even get a better position too
because this pawn is a bit uh
weak
so if i take
oh there's knight g5
if i take here
i'll take here
but if takes i play this intake
the rook might get hugged i know i can't
or maybe it can
that looks okay though
oh i have this no i don't have this move
because takes
uh
okay my rook is getting hugged
it's not quite trapped
there's c5 maybe queen e7
and 25 eventually
it looks weird to play without a rook
that move i forgot about
i'm probably in some trouble now
i want to take this
i want i'll play this move now
just doesn't work
this move
also this move
i think i'll play this move
it looks really really risky
it may be playable
there's also this i should consider
hi eric wow ow ow wow
hi
oh there's knight h82 funny move
which just kind of loses
[Music]
it's not pleasant
i'm holding on for dear life here
i was thinking queen h6
my f4 is also kind of interesting
also probably just losing
in h6
[Music]
oh that doesn't work
try this
also high
also i'm completely losing if white
finds the right move
is white to move in with people on the
puzzle
or is it so simple that's so simple
yeah
it's completely winning for white
what to do
[Music]
there goes my position
okay
oh it was rough
it might already be losing after rook
off one
yeah
i was looking for a defense but
a smart
choice from lights
okay i guess i another game started will
be zurich i'll play this move
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna move quicker
oh no
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
okay no more more sound effects
oh i'm playing spicy food
okay
let's eat some spicy food oh no i'm
outside top 50.
okay serious chest time
okay no more berserk losing
let me bring the queen to h4
the promised land
i was already completely winning for
white
okay let's go add some spicy food
back on track
where am i
hey top 50 again
okay
of 303
i'm playing other people around my same
rank so
it's important not to lose to people
i think variants only
beserk
this line
um
[Music]
i'm in trouble
b
ah
i'm so slow
i was going for the dirty flag
what to do
okay still top 50.
i remember this game that was a fun game
okay
going into this line
this is a fun line
i think you fired up for the burn
something for five months
yeah still
prep
uh
there should be two i don't think i've
seen before
might as well take
okay block is winning
this move
maybe this move
always have to watch out for these ideas
i'm up a full rook
for a couple pawns
f6
it'll be seven hangs
complete blind spot
it's not so simple now
um
i want to play this but then queens
would double check
there's rook c8
and
you can see three
[Music]
i think maybe just casting an h4
it's getting tricky though
arguing this this this this
it's just a big mess
maybe this first
preventing queen d5
means tied down to defending the bishop
my opponent thought they could queen but
okay life is better now
thank you rip and chen
solving with prime for the first time
having made in one
f2 really couldn't be defended there
okay
hey 44. i hopped over a lot of people
[Music]
boppity-hoppity
okay we're approaching i should play e5
there we're approaching the final hour
hello hope you are well this is an
awesome channel
oh thank you forensic life coach
hope you're well too
subbing for two months
there is this move and after which i
have to go back
here i'll probably still go for this
h4h5 plan
maybe throw in some knight h3
going for g4 now
hi eric have an internship interview
soon wish me luck smile oh good luck
smile
trying to figure out what's going on
here
i want to play uh
g4 but
it's tricky
maybe just this move
just play very positionally trade queens
yeah thank you mr mango dude
stay focused do your best
probably want to take on
e6 soon
g4 eventually
another idea is bishop e2 id f4
but then i get my queen dropped
but bishop b2 over defends f3 so
g4 i still want to play
someday
oh no my pawn
okay there's something i got five ideas
now
thank you dk with the j
new tier one sub
yeah that five looks nice actually
i mean it's kind of a big trade
but now i get the g file open
another foreign coming
i'm gonna try and finish strong
are you participating in the crumbling
squid games
i am yeah i was one of the last minute
entries
i originally i declined because i was
going to go to lafayette but
i kind of fell through and now
[Music]
i'll be in the squid
i think it's just called squid chess
it's tomorrow tomorrow morning
i think
to check the exact time
where's my win
queen here
some funny line like takes rook h1 etc
the line is actually takes never mind
i was also thinking here
maybe that's not so simple
oh there's a nice line okay so it takes
and then just takes
and then rook g1
also threading made in one
i assume this works i mean i didn't
calculate king h5 but
there's queen d1
in g4 mate
yeah with that move
maybe i just take
i'll temporarily lose my knight
but
i'm gonna win the night back
i'm also threatening to take take and
quadruple fork oh ah that's not gonna
happen
the quadruple fork of all the major
pieces would have been really nice
yeah so now i'm just finding the
singular fork
the best way to do this
good evening eric tourney seems to be
going well you get a trophy for top 100
don't you i do what's your best finish
in one of these marathons
top overall position oh i'm not actually
sure
there might be a way to look that up
if you go to my profile and see like my
previous
uh yeah you can probably click in
marathon top 50
the two top 50s before
also welcome back stephen gray hope you
got some nice rest
time to go for the kill now
oh except i'm not really
uh let's play this move
i can't take because then i force mate
this
rook is now pinned
i just want to simplify
uh
[Music]
back
back
oh i was about to blunder a rook that
would have been bad
maybe this move
it's hard to stay focused for like so so
long
let's go okay
avoided blundering a rook
yeah there's trophy for top 50 i believe
hey thank you step work
cheering 450
my placing times 10
and thank you read the book thank you
lord francesco gifting to triple and
nello
appointment rate of 24.50 okay zerk
staffer gambit time
his opening is a little bit sus but i'm
trying to make it work
i think you read the book
15.5
okay probably want to go for the
t-pawn push
don't mind the queen trade
and put the rook on the
f-file
bring the king in
it's going to turn very positional i'll
put a rook on f4
and bring my other rook to f6 probably
then just milk
this position like a cow
maybe my king can come in
your frequent opponent manitoli plomo is
in third he must have stayed awake
wow that's actually really crazy
yeah we played a lot last night
or this morning
oh
yeah probably stay the wake
also how am i gonna win this
let's go okay i want a pawn i want
another pawn
[Music]
i'm winning so many pawns
or am i f7 is kind of hanging
it's still not super clear but it should
be winning
opponent just got a little bit careless
there
let's go okay
another w
uh
[Music]
what's berserk i don't know if this is
appalling berserk's back
they don't
ah this game okay let's take let's play
something a bit more aggressive
i do f3 e4
just trying to play a dragon setup
good morning from singapore amazing that
you're at it again i am i am it's been a
long tournament
we're just about in the final hour
oh i missed this move kind of
let's play this
some idea to play this
queen e8 i think is forced
maybe it takes and bishop takes f4
knight g4
that's hard to judge
okay so that was a point
jump upon now
again i don't have increments so it's
gonna be tough
i'll play this and win f7
okay now i'm finding this
a6 takes and then c4 probably
i still want to play this
not quite winning
the knight back
back hello
hello
i think two different forks
blocks pieces are very forkable
okay going in for the kill now
there we go
yeah that's a free pawn
i'm just trying to trap the knight
e7 rxe6
[Music]
[Music]
wait what
oh i forgot how it goes
i forget like the tune
i think something big bang
it's so late it's hard to say things
but it's easy to pin things
let's go okay
let's go
oh hello to neil what's up neil welcome
back
hey top 40 34th
the goal's top 30
which might be doable
okay
already slightly confusing
[Music]
almost a baby
a
little emc 42
a
i have to play quicker let's play this
move being the knight
i want to take i mean the queen was
hanging so
[Music]
play this
risky move but it's interesting
along the center
backing f2 now
this position is so confusing
looks good for black
a lot of things happening
[Music]
oh my queen
let's go okay
okay somehow i won that
i dropped a queen but
i felt like i was playing well that game
i just came down to dirtiness
let's go that's five in a row
three berserk wins in a row
variants only
i think they're deserved
opponent loss or opponent beat me before
so
like to go for revenge
what's quack-a-lackin i woke up at the
quack of dawn just in time to duck a
christmas quacker being tossed at my
head
anyways enjoy these bits you can put it
on my bill
oh thank you lord
francesco have assumed that came from
duck but
i appreciate that
uh let's play this
this move
maybe g4 ideas
i can take and
back
fix
try this first
[Music]
it's going to come down to a time
scramble
no queen trade for you
okay double attack
take this first
the ship's now hanging
let's go okay
was that six in a row
six in a row
trying to close in on top 30.
i don't know if this player beserks
but i'm on a berserking streak so i have
to keep berserking
thank you forensic life coach
oh and doc
hamsters are the best beginners pet you
don't have to feed them and they only
live for three days
also quack
i don't know if that's
how
bats are supposed to work
okay
it's actually still theory
it's a topical variation b7 is the main
move
okay e4
this is uh stockfish versus alpha no
alpha zero versus stockfish
2000
2019
it was from their famous match in london
[Music]
it was one of the only games featuring a
london opening
e4 was a novelty at the time
there's some cool ideas i mean of course
the critical moves are takes or takes
sockfish did play this which is the best
move
now the threat is this there's only one
move for black not to lose
fill in prep
the thing is the position is really
complicated if black plays the right
move
it's been a while since i've looked at
this line so closely yeah queen b4 is
the best move
oh no my knight
black can take it once
just not twice
so i'm up on time i just don't have
agreement
play rookie one
might as well take in place for vaguely
remember some ideas of
hacking
and it's called forgiven the structure
there might be some cool greek gift at
some point
this first
take on
i don't think it works though
my box getting really low on time i have
to keep moving quickly too
[Music]
uh does this work now
it might work let's do it
the point is i have rook be oh wait
oh i don't ah
i thought everything was coming with
check
the point is i have this move coming
[Music]
hopefully
uh there's g6
maybe this first
it's complicated now
who's hanging though
and
[Music]
go
let's go okay got the job done a nice
little opening prep
okay 31st place
what's that seven eight in a row dealing
with fire
the berserking won't stop
swan sawn over the sea swim swam swim
swan swam back again well swamped swan
i do have my
is patiently waiting to be worn but
let's not wear it too soon
it's scandi
i want to play coddus
this
my position is a little bit passive but
still looks playable
when you seven i'm not sure which side
to castle
i'll be king side now
eventually
yo i'm getting forked
e6 was such a bad move
let's try and fight
i take on
keep the bishop
to avoid trades and keep the position
tense and threaten sneaky mates
triple fork me
or maybe coming
he's almost trapped
maybe
a post
[Music]
oh no
okay back to tournaments
there was my streak
it was fun while it lasted for how
fleeting are all human passions compared
to the massive continuity of ducks also
keep going eric also quack
quack oh hi
okay
uh
you knew this person before okay zerk
trying to regain the berserking streak
it's dangerous though
and my bishop should be on f4
opponent has way more time than they
started with
i like the position though
castle
top 30 here he comes let's go eric
i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying
it's not easy
31st place though
i'm close
this is a critical game
i'll take and play this f5 i've reroute
to e5
queen c6 i playbook h4
oh funny line here never mind
knight has a hard time getting back in
the game
i mean not four i have this winning
immediately
yeah
tuned in this morning utc and you're
still going what a machine
i did take a break to sleep for several
hours
this is my second stream of this
tournament
yeah it's been a lot of streaming of
chess
coming back
tv
okay i wouldn't mind the queen trade
f3 when the time is right
oh there's f4 coming
hope for the best
we'll come to d3
it's a bit tricky for black not to get
forked
did this move now
i'm hitting the rock
this is one fork
remember eric it's a marathon not a
sprint
but also remember eric right now it's
sort of a sprint
[Music]
and print the finish of the mirror
i'm just going for cheap tricks
done so well of not
working
oh
okay
okay this one berserks
recover
32nd place
london opening time
main line
yeah i think bishop d3 makes sense
wow what
i'll take care
a free pawn
it's confusing though
this is castle queen sign
it's just a trade
well played
takes
a little bit of trouble here
mailbox in trouble
you see my
still
[Music]
no
ah i'm so slow oh
i was a little bit too slow there
i just lost track of time
okay still within range
very much within range of top 30.
it's gonna be close though
i've made in one
i really
[Music]
i had made in one
in the final position ah i had made in
one
i had made one in the final position
queen d4 mate
that's so sad
okay sapphire gamba time
[Music]
queenie two i think is actually the best
move
okay nobody's working this game
i think c3 is the only move here
weirdly enough
okay i want to go for the light square
massaging
and there's knight h3
bishop h3
okay there's a lot of good looking
options here i think i'll start with
should start with this rook actually
queen is attacked
now there's this idea
if this i play this
yeah it's not already under pressure
here
maybe threatening this
a bold move
i guess if i play this there's
rook takes
right with this
there's a funny lie
it doesn't work thinking bishop b7 takes
takes takes but
loses material
i'll start with this
i guess this
oh no
i think as i saw this idea against e5
yeah it's just a blunder
to do
well maybe
it's not good
still a tiny ounce of hope
f6
i'm down a piece
that was a nice looking position too
it's probably worth resigning pretty
soon
you never know
you never know
it's late in the tournament
opponent's probably tired too
good move
and a five
hoping for a miracle
tracking different things
this is kind of what i want just a
unexpectedly complicated situation
i mean my things are hanging but white
has some stuff hanging too
it's also getting kind of low on time
i was on the verge of resigning but
yeah there's still hope
or is there
take the thing
i take
i should probably take that i mean
there's
take first
i'm still alive
here i can take
get some rook ending
there's also king maybe king g8
overcome
it's still losing it's a problem
okay i'll go into this
oh i didn't see that ah i didn't see
that
okay
a little bit low on top
thing up
visual short style
[Music]
back
back
okay i didn't deserve to win that
it's a swindle let's go
i needed that too 31st place
back on track
i don't know how that happened i was
just down there full rook
and my my king walked up
being helped with a mating
attack finishing with a sprint
i think this is playable actually
inside down to the knight
with c6 i can play this
95
before
actually let's be solid e3
why don't you go for another four
is this move
the pawn tension now
[Music]
this is a weakness
defend the e pawn first
in the f on later
oh fancy move
okay
that's not to meet
[Music]
plenty of time
let's go okay
top 30
maybe 29 let's go okay
mission accomplished
now can i finish top 20
i have 20 minutes left
let's play this line anti-danish gambit
up upon here
let's move
find the square for the night
there we go
[Music]
do this
weird but
logic to it
ah i got forked
it's still probably okay f3 is weak
if white keeps checking me i think i'll
run to
[Music]
a5
or a6
there's b6 and king a6
wait don't meet me
am i getting made it no
let's play this
okay that was kind of a close call
yeah this is a very important move
let's go
27th
21st is 13 points away that's two
berserk wins no three bizarre wins away
oh opponent beat me before and they
don't berserk either
it was a mistake to resurrect this
opponent
everything a
very open position
yes we're in some end game
they'll have a minute left
e5
i want to play a6 i think
a6 is kind of nice
94 probably coming
no i got forks
wait what just happened
what happened was the draw
of the draw
i tried clicking claim draw but my
opponent claimed it before me so then
the button changed from claim draw to
back to tournament
i was expecting king g3 but opponent was
kind of kind to me
okay
i think i'm positioning the rest of my
games
a lot of people are berserking back
i don't usually play this opening
[Music]
g3 kings indian
takes takes
uh might as well
d5 coming
looks pleasant
that's an idea too
nice time advantage
bishop c3 was more painful there
there should be six i guess
position's not great but
time is good
okay king activity
i'm down the pawn but uh this position
actually looks pretty nice
[Music]
okay let's go
26th place
i'm just trying to sprint play as many
games as possible in the last 13 minutes
a lot of players not berserking back
what some players do
another victim to bishop a6
not a victim yet i still have to prove
myself but
this is a nice trap
of
i guess queen a5 is one of the best
moves
taken when
when a pawn with better structure
and prevent black from castling
oh
probably should not have allowed that
uh awkward situation here
i took a lot of time there too
yeah let's plan this to
get c4 in
accomplished
i'm up upon
not so much time though
i doubled a pawn what is this
oh good
i'm trying to fight
no i love queen c1
i was trying to set up the thing
uh
what to do
make you a flock
okay life goes on
i'll play a reverse closed sicilian
setup
yeah this could be one of the last games
trying to make every game count
i already accomplished my goal though
top 30.
as well take
go for uh c6
oh thanks for one of the last game bits
yeah
i think games
will be left
ideally more than two
it's risky to just go all out for the
win
the attack doesn't work
i have to believe
i want to play f4 but then e4 is
annoying
maybe i just win connect 4
5 h4
i work on c7
okay connect four
it comes to c5 maybe
pushing
and now the knight wants to come to c5
it takes i play this
maybe win something
i vote that eric starts a new tournament
after this one chat also quack also go
eric
also i'm about to flag
okay pawns are smiling
six
okay
i have a battery but there's a pin
a lot of pawn tension here
g4 kills all my fun
i'm still having some
oh looks defended
uh
what to do this
more checks finding the pawn
thanks for the great chess
oh thank you
unless
i'm down
enough
maybe i can pull off some
penis
is
this is why king pond endings are so
important
does white know how to win this
let's go
draw hey
i didn't know how to win it
do we have time for one more game it's
time for one more i'll have to give a
lesson how to win that kingpin ending
oh pairings are closed okay
i didn't end on a loss
what the finish wow
i mean
so this this position is drawn i
pre-moved the wrong move um because i
didn't have any time left
uh
black would keep opposition
but this position
is winning for twice
king f6 was a wrong move
um like play king h7 and i would have to
repeat
but
wait where did white go wrong oh yeah so
king f7 here wins
the zerusus and then the pawn queens
uh but if we go back
so the
correct way to win is king g6 king here
and then not this because king h7 and
then there's uh the stale matrix
but to play king h6 and then the timing
works out
i'm chased to the center
anyway tournament
top 30 is very impressive especially
considering the sleep
yeah i didn't play the whole thing
i played 10 hours and now
five hours about 15
hours so
what like
two-thirds
i can't do math
or three-fifths
about three-fifths
okay
well good job to everyone good job to
this person who beat me a handful of
times
your frequent opponent finished at third
place
oh yeah i played i played all these guys
everyone who finished top 10 i'm pretty
sure i played at some points
great marathon congrats
oh thank you mr turlosaurus
i appreciate all the
kindness and generosity
absolute chess machine well played all
day and thanks again
oh thank you silverback hq
donating 26 dollars for 26th place
did the quad ever happen
no i i've tried so many times it didn't
happen
a lot of people just played sicilian
i played king's gambit so many times i
didn't play a single ponziani in this
tournament
also
i kinda like
based on silverback hq's donation of 26
dollars
if i finished in 24 000 place
would the donation be 24 000
oh maybe i i've
had the wrong tournament strategy
because the higher i finish
[Music]
the lower the
the amount
almost as tasty as my staffer gabbas